so strange I look at him now and I know
that he killed my mom and now he's gonna
pay for it you've seen who I am you know
what I can do every bad thing that has
happened to us it was him I promise you
Mary Ellen you will die then face me now
where are you
Wells is in the building he's coming
this way come on we gotta get out of
here don't worry we'll stop him
you into my life all of our lives a half
we ready to face him hear him the
reverse-flash
we let him go
oh my god kill him how easy
hey youtubers is Charlie thank you
everyone that asks questions about the
flash and arrow this week there's also a
bunch of news about the spin-off new
character you know maybe cyborg has been
cast on the show so I'm going to start
with that first and then I'm just going
to go through all the really big arrow
flash questions so the big news is is
that an actor named Franz drum a I don't
really know how to pronounce his last
name so I might be butchering that was
cast as Jay Jackson the official
description of his character reads a
former high school athlete who's pro
career was derailed by injury now making
ends meet is an auto mechanic Jay will
come to have a surprising affiliation to
the STAR Labs crew so looking at the
actor they cast we know the characters
african-american leading to you know
like two or three really big
possibilities the most likely one is
he's going to be cyborg or version of
cyborg the Victor stones cyborg has
always been tight his origin has always
been tied to STAR Labs you know all the
way from the classic comics through the
new 52 if you don't read the comics the
new 52 origin story is the one that they
told in the Justice League war cartoon
the one where the mother box technology
fuses with him and he becomes a cyborg
that way in the classic comics it was
like an alien that came through a portal
that mutated him in his father who
worked at STAR Labs created the
cybernetic parts to help him survive the
mutation almost the same thing just a
little bit different I know a lot of you
are asking you know how can they do
cyborg on the TV show if they're going
to be doing him in the Batman V Superman
movie in Justice League well it is
possible like they are doing that with a
couple other characters Slade Wilson the
destro character is the best example
Marc Guggenheim said the Deathstroke was
not off the table on the TV show even
though he's probably going to appear in
the Suicide Squad movie so not all movie
characters are off-limits to the TV
shows the only bad thing about that is
that there's no hard and fast rule it's
like a case-by-case basis Deadshot is
the best example that like Will Smith is
gonna be playing Deadshot so I think the
DC was like okay he's such a big actor
we don't want to have anyone else
playing him who knows what kind of
conversations go on behind the scenes
but cyborg being a very tech based
character feels like he fits really well
with the the Ray Palmer character as
well as Martin Stein very science tech
oriented so you know it seems like
that's going to be the basis of the team
as opposed to like a Magic based Justice
Society or Justice League dark
moving down the list of possibilities
you know slightly less likely wally west
the TV show already confirmed they're
going to do a version of him eventually
so rewind to last year whenever they
were casting the brandon ralph ray
palmer character initially his character
description read as the Ted Kord Blue
Beetle I obviously behind the scenes
things changed and they needed to make
him the atom instead of the Blue Beetle
so the arrow flash people could be
running some interference just to
confuse comic book readers and saying
you know J Jackson doing like a funny
alliteration thing to be Wally West
you know ww2 JJ I think it's a little
bit early to be bringing the Wally West
flash on the TV show I on say I think
that they're gonna hold that off for a
little bit and it's it's gonna flow from
a storyline on the flash not the
spin-off show that's why I think the
Wally West flash is just slightly less
likely and I think when they bring that
character on he will be called Wally
West he won't be called some other name
so unless they're lying to us Jay
Jackson is not going to be Wally West so
one more time moving like slightly down
the list of possibilities there's the
static shock character I know everybody
really wants to see him in the TV show
universe at some point they're making a
live-action show like they're developing
a live-action show just for him so I
don't think that static shock is going
to be on the spin-off show the way they
described the Jay Jackson character
makes it sound like he's going to be
kind of a cisco type person that just
you know wisecracks a lot and comments
on all the craziness of what you know
what they're going on chasing down
metahumans that's kind of the energy you
get from the cyborg character in the new
52 universe just like what's going on
here this is absolutely crazy they're
aliens flying around everywhere
super-powered people so based on the
information we have all signs point to
cyborg but you know again they could be
lying to us and using a fake name fake
description
it could be someone totally different
let me know what you guys think though
you know which character is this J
Jackson character is he cyborg is he
static shock is he someone else so
moving on to arrow in the flash this
week just I'm going to start with the
canary cry like the really big stuff
first I know everyone's wondering
whenever laurels gonna use that the
first time she's actually seen doing it
in the promo for the next episode so I
actually I think we're going to see it
in the next episode just like all the
suits all the tech on air on the flash I
think the canary cry is gonna evolve
over time like Cisco will make little
tweaks to it as they go along so don't
be surprised if we get to season four in
the cry sounds just like a
a little bit different although watching
Laurel scream like this just gets me so
excited don't you wonder if when they
were auditioning the character they had
her scream because you know they were
auditioning characters knowing that they
would become Black Canary like okay you
just read dialog with this other
character it sounds like you can do
great drama now show us how you scream a
lot of you guys were also asking if if
when Cisco gave her the canary cry
choker if it was a vibe easter-egg
because he said he'd been working with
sound waves that was actually a callback
to Pied Piper I know everyone wants to
know when Caitlin's going to become
killer frost and Cisco is going to
become vibe the way they made it sound
like in all the panels that they've done
is that Caitlin will become killer frost
before Cisco becomes vibe so what I
think is going to happen is is will get
some killer frost teasers by the finale
and then in season two like we'll slowly
be moving towards a Cisco vibe for those
that are asking about you know
metahumans - just just remember they
said there's a certain logic to who they
give metahuman powers to and who gets to
be a tech based character the Rogues are
a good example some of them have tech
some of them have metahuman powers the
ones that are metahumans are the ones
that don't have the ability to create
their own tech the really hardcore
science based characters like Cisco are
probably going to be creating their own
tech Caitlin is a very smart scientist
but she's more of a biologist so she
gets powers it's more likely that she
would become a metahuman so hopefully
that answers some of your vibe killer
frost questions but you know mostly that
you know canary cry choker sound waves
that was more of a reference to Pied
Piper next big question Cisco dying in
the promo so I know a lot of you are
asking you know is that going to be the
shape shifter that he kills or is it
going to be something from the other
timeline this promo seems like it's only
from the next episode maybe you know
maybe the next two episodes because we
see Harrison wells inside a prison I'm
actually thinking that this version of
Cisco that's being killed in the promo
is the shapeshifter Hannibal Bates it's
totally possible that like that you know
Harrison wells behind the glass could
have been from footage that was cut out
of last week's episode so this version
of Cisco could really be Cisco from
another timeline
moving on to Justice League stuff I know
everyone was asking if the the police
mural with the Greek gods on it was a
Justice League Easter Egg you could look
at it that way I mean you know Jay
Garrick's hat looks an awful lot like
mercury
max mercury was a speedster too so yeah
I mean you could you could draw all
kinds of references to that I don't
think it was so much a reference to
anything that would be happening on the
show in the future I think it was more
of a wink to the comics it's not a hint
that the show is going to be doing
Justice League anytime soon
although the team-up show is actually
like the next best thing it's the same
deal with you know with the Wayne
Enterprises Easter egg in the future
newspaper they keep showing is it's not
like we're ever going to see Wayne
Enterprises on the flash TV show but it
exists so it's like them just kind of
winking at us so moving up to like
finale big team-up stuff I know
everyone's asking about you know
firestorm and how it's going to work
with the spin-off show in martin stein
being separate characters so in this
image we see Rachael Mel the flash and
firestorm getting ready to go up against
the reverse-flash
what I think is going to happen with the
finale is is it will be like a rolling
episode that'll crossover episode like
22 and 23 so like you know both episodes
will just flow into one another whether
or not it's like a traditional
two-parter remains to be seen but you
know typically that's what they do with
the the arrow finales is is they just
kind of make this big story that crosses
two or three episodes add to that
Stephen Amell is on the show so there
will probably be some sort of like arrow
flash crossover whether or not it
involves time-travel you know universe
altering consequences remains to be seen
there's been a lot of rumors that some
WTF will happen in the arrow finale then
the week after that in the flash finale
they'll be time travel that'll totally
mess with that but that son confirmed as
for Ronnie Raymond and Martin Stein
firestorm there is precedence in the
comics for Ronnie Raymond to be able to
become firestorm by himself so I think
the show is slowly moving towards that
if you remember that Fight Club promo
that they posted with them finding each
other in Thunderdome
you see Martin Stein actually standing
on the sidelines watching firestorm in
the battle you could look at that as
evidence that the TV show is going to
separate those characters permanently so
that Robbie Amell can play the firestorm
character on his own without Martin
Stein Martin Stein is just one of the
confirmed spin-off characters and even
though captain cold and heatwave are
also confirmed for the spin-off that
doesn't mean that they're leaving the
flash because the spin-off show is
probably going to air whenever the flash
and arrow are on break whether it's the
winner or the summer the good thing
about it not airing at the same time is
that it allow
characters to go back and forth between
all the shows like they don't have to
permanently leave one show to go to the
other we don't have a whole lot of other
details about the spin-off you know
other than I'm expecting some sort of
like promo moment after the finale of
the flash thank you everyone for so many
questions for these are always a ton of
fun to do you know hopefully they tell
us a little bit more about the spin-off
show by the time we get to comic-con
comic-con just like at the beginning of
July this year so it's a lot earlier and
they haven't really started filming the
spin-off show yet they might be getting
ready to they'll already have like an
arrow season 4 trailer by the time we
get to comic-con so hopefully they will
have some footage to show off from the
spin-off series but new episodes next
week so be sure to subscribe to get them
I'm also working on some daredevil
videos that I'm going to try and get out
by Saturday I want it I want to start
doing some daredevil season 2 stuff but
I got to get through the rest of my
season 1 videos don't forget a beggar's
age of Ultron also in theaters most
places now should be out by next week in
the United States be sure to go see it
it's a lot of fun if you haven't seen it
yet you can actually click here for my
non-spoilery age of Ultron review and
you can click here for my arrow on flash
episodes from this week thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you